Hey Youtubers It's Charlie Happy Blizzcon,
we finally get the official Warcraft trailer
so let's break it down.
real quick reminder to I'm doing a giveaway
for one of the purchasable epic mounts all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
So if you guys were watching the feed this
morning they they introduced some of the cast
on stage most of the people most the big characters
we see in this trailer
just to place the movie in the timeline it
kinda picks up where the first game picks
up with the orcs and humans as you can see
the narrative of the game Ogrim is like the
protagonist of the orcs he's going to try
and form an alliance with the humans both
are here is kind like his counterpart but
obviously on the orcs side your people like
Clancy Brown playing black hand who are can
be really happy about that yet King Lane rent
Dominic Cooper here who isn't sure what to
do in and swirling in the background we have
cooled down and made the so so obviously they're
going to have their own agenda to despite
the fact that they're both serving the orcs
in the humans yay for squishy cloth wearers
it is really fun seeing little baby thrall
there just locality he is this is also one
of our first looks at Durotan he's the leader
of one of the other work factions but if it's
not clear during the orc narrative despite
the fact that they have all these big characters
Ogrim is the main character really I think
of this is like all grim in Lothar's movie
in they use have a bunch of other big characters
in it looks like were getting a taste of the
burning Legion so I'm guessing that's workable
that comes in and that provides some of the
impetus for all grim to try and form an alliance
with the humans remember this is just the
first of many movies so if you're up on your
Warcraft Lord you know bolt and stretches
across the lot of work leaders and a lot of
them appear in this movie some expecting cold
on the deep some of the bigger background
characters to carry forward in any future
movies and they do it just to in the official
Warcraft lore cooldown manipulates a lot of
the orcs like all grim ends up battling with
a lot of the other chieftains eventually gold
uninstalls Blackhand here Clancy Brown's character
as the puppet leader of the United horde will
send to talk about Garona's character because
it seems like she's going to be a link between
orcs in humans although secretly she's part
training I don't know how they're going to
figure into this movie it seems like this
movie is mostly focusing on the conflict between
orcs in humans so I'm I'm not expecting a
whole lot of trainees step maybe Easter eggs
for future movies so I think for the short
term were disposed to think of her as a link
between orcs in humans but you know that Nina
secretly at the end of the movie they might
find out that she's part training and then
push that into the second movie will say I
think it just depends on how successful this
first movie is I think they want to keep it
as simple as possible in Warcraft Lord gets
really complicated game of thrones does the
same thing when it adapts stuff for the TV
show like it just it makes a little bit more
linear little bit easier to follow the good
thing is is that this is successful enough
to spin it out into a big marvel universe
and you get all kinds a Warcraft movies probably
StarCraft movies to eventually but what I'm
really hoping that we see one of the big surprises
I'm hoping to see his Gul'dan invoking Sargeras
something big from the burning Legion either
Kil'jaden Archemonde Sargeras there has to
be some villains that's bigger than the orcs
in the humans like they'll be fighting each
other but they have to unite because some
bigger threat from the burning Legion comes
along we are way too early for the Lich King
not expecting a whole lot of dragons either
but in terms of progression just expect the
movies to fall the timeline of the games with
the idea that if they cut things out they
might bring them back later like if they don't
reference the Draeni in the first movie they
might bring them on later or if we don't need
Sargeras in the first movie we might need
in the second or the third of a whole bunch
of movies and blizzard Activision just launched
the TV and film studios to the Mexican any
producing a lot more content I mean it's starting
with call of duty and sky Landers that eventually
you'll see Warcraft and StarCraft TV shows
I think like a lot of other big film things
they want to do it just depends on how successful
this first movie is I think it's going to
be awesome but I all say like the biggest
thing that I'm looking forward to is seeing
the burning Legion just wrecked everybody
and if you didn't see it I just posted a Star
Wars trailer video so after you get through
all that footage and you get to all the awesome
footage while watching the blues can't be
be sure to update all of your blizzard games
and she's had the login for the first time
in a week or two to update Hearthstone Warcraft
and StarCraft two I totally admit to just
auto buying anything that blizzard sells so
even though I have a plate StarCraft two in
a while I'm I'm totally auto buying legacy
the void I feel like you have to one of the
big knocks against destiny is the fact that
it has almost no narrative is almost no Lore
there's almost no story blizzard is one of
the best companies when it comes to stuff
like that they have special people on the
team whose job is only to develop the lore
everybody grab your raid gear watch the trailer
couple more times, here I'll add a link so
you can here loop the trailer forever and
and you can click here for the new Star Wars
trailer I posted.
thank you so much for watching everybody let's
high five and I'll see you guys this weekend!